y una congregación de miles en un lugar
santo es la noche del destino del
ramadán una oración que volvió a verse
empañada por la violencia desde hace
semanas la explanada de las mezquitas un
lugar santo para el islam y el judaísmo
es escenario de enfrentamientos y no
quieren que recemos hay una lucha cada
día hay enfrentamientos nos han estado
impidiendo que entremos los palestinos
denuncian que las fuerzas de seguridad
les han impedido reunirse para sus
oraciones las autoridades aseguran que
hay provocaciones desde este grupo de
personas el reciente anuncio de posibles
desalojos en jerusalén este una zona en
disputa ha reivindicado la agitación
entre las dos partes
todo esto con un panorama político
incierto tanto en israel como en
cisjordania uno sin gobierno y otro con
elecciones aplazadas
además con la atención de parte de la
comunidad internacional el sábado el
presidente turco recep tayip erdogán
cargó contra el ejecutivo israelí en el
estado cruel y de terror de israel no
tiene misericordia y ataca de manera
inmoral a los musulmanes en jerusalén
cuya única meta era defender sus
creencias y los que han sido sus hogares
por miles de años
eeuu en rusia la unión europea de
naciones unidas han expresado
recientemente de estar preocupados por
esta situación